ينضم الينا من طهران علي رضا عنايه مساعد
وزير الخارجيه الايراني والمدير العام
لدائره شؤون الخليجيه في الخارجيه
الايرانيه مرحبا بك سيد علي اذا نتنياهو
عاد الى السلطه حكومه هي الاكثر تطرفا كما
توصف والاكثر يمينيه في اسرائيل
والبرنامج او البند الاول في برنامج
نتنياهو
السعي لمنع حصول ايران على سلاح النووي
كيف ستتعامل طهران مع هذا التطور
السلام عليكم وعلى مشاهديكم مشاهد
مشاهدينا الكرام ااا
طبعا ايران لا تبحث عن
السلاح النووي حتى ياتي احدا ويتكلم عنه
ملف ايران النووي واضح جدا ف
دخلت ايران في مفاوضات جاده مع مجموعه
خمسه زائد واحد سابقا
واربعه زائد واحد لاحقا في همم في
الدفاع عن حقه المشروع
للاستخدام او همم
تكنولوجيا للطاقه الذريه وهذا الملف واضح
بشهاده الوكاله الدولي
للطاقه الذريه وايران هي مبتعده عن همم عن
الحديث عن السلاح النووي
اه اا اتصور لا يوجد مجال في الحديث عن
هذا الامر هل تستشعرون خطرا من اسرائيل
وسبق امكانت هناك تهديدات ربما حتى
بمحاوله همم ضرب اهداف
داخل ايران من قبل اسرائيل
اا ممم نسمع بين حين واخر مثل هذه
التهديدات ايران ليست لقطه من هذه
التهديدات وفي نفس الوقت همم هي جاهزه
للرد على اي اعتداء ايران همم
تتحدث همم بلغه السلام ولا تلتفت الى مثل
هذه التهتدات طب اذا اردنا ان همم نستغل
وجودك للسؤال عن بعض القضايا المتعلقه
بامن همم المنطقه ايضا كان هناك مؤتمر
شارك فيه وزير الخارجيه لايراني في منطقه
البحر الميت مؤتمر بشان الامن الاقليمي
بشان العراق تحديدا ما الذي خرجت منه
ايران ب همم هذا همم مؤتمر او من هذا
المؤتمر
اه حضرنا المؤتمر في دورتيه بغداد ال
اول وبغداد الثاني في العراق وفي الاردن
وايران كانت حاضره في
هاتين الدورتين
واؤكد واقول بان ايران دائما كانت حاضره
وجاهزه في دعم العراق قبل همم هذا المؤتمر
وقلنا مرارا بان ايران مع العراق قبل
المؤتمر حين المؤتمر وبعد المؤتمر اما همم
كيف همم همم
تعاملت ايران مع المؤتمر في الجانب همم
السياسي نحن اكلنا دعمنا للعمليه السياسيه
همم في العراق
وكنا بجانب العراق في هذه العمليه العراق
الجديد المبني على اراده همم الشعب
العراقيين في المؤتمر الذين شاردتهم الى
جانب جانبهم في هذا المؤتمر يرون بان
ايران جزء من المشكله في العراق
وليست جزءا همم من الحل او بمعنى اخر هي
همم جزء من الخلاف القائم داخل المكونات
العراقيه ووجودها بشكل او باخر في العراق
هو مشكله بالنسبه اليهم
طبعا انا كنت يعني من ضمن المشاركين في
مؤتمر بغداد الاول والمؤتمر بغداد الثاني
للتعاون
والشراكه وانا لم اسمع عن مثل هذه
العبارات في
الكلمات التي القيت وحقيقه انا اريد ان
ااه
اشيد بمثل هذا المؤتمر الذي جمع فيه
كثيرون في الاجتماع الاخير 12 12 دوله همم
وكل هذه الدول تحدثت بلغه همم
الحوار والمشاركه والمساعده ولم يتحدث احد
في هذه
الندوات او في هذا المنتدى همم في توجيه
الاتهام الى الطرف الاخر واا نحن نحبك مثل
همم هذه المنتديات التي بنيت على ثقافه
الحوار ودون ان نتتهم همم الطرف الاخر او
الطرف الاخر يتهم الطرف الثاني ففي
الحقيقي يجلس
المشاركون والمجتمعون ويتحدثون عن موضوع
واحد وطبعا همم العراق في همم هذا همم في
هذه في هذا المنتدى كانت نقطه الالتقاء
النقطه التغاء الجميع والجميع عبروا عن
رؤاهم
وفكرتهم تجاه العراق مثل ما تحدث في
الجانب السياسي وفي الجانب الاقتصادي وفي
الجانب الامني وحقيقه كل المشاركين همم
تكلموا عن عن العراق وايضا نحن في خطاب او
في كلمه معالي الوزير الايراني اكد بان
الحوار والتعاون هو ليس انتخابا بل ضروري
لهذا الاقليم
تاكدنا مع الجميع لاستطباب الامر على على
سيره ال همم
اللقاءات التي حصلت ايضا واا النقاشات كان
هناك لقاء لافت بين وزيري الخارجيه
الايراني والسعودي على هامش هذا المؤتمر
همم على ما تم الاتفاق وما الذي تم بحثه
في هذا لقاء
همم طبعا همم مثل ما ذكرتهم يعني
الهوامش في بعض الاحيان يعني
مهمه ايضا في هامش اللقاء كان همم سلحت
الفرصه اللي
الحوار الودي الودي بين وزير خارجيه ايران
وزير خارجيه المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وتحدث الجانبان عن رؤاهم تجاه همم الجولات
السابقه في الحوار اللي تمت في بغداد وانا
اغتنم الفرصه واشكر اخواننا العراقيين ل-
همم دورهم البناء في هذا المجال لتقريبه
وجهاد نظر
الايرانيين والسعوديين وهمم عبر عبر
الطرفان ارتياحهم اللي همم هذه الجولات
واعلن
استعداداهما
للمضيء قدما واتخاذ خطوات اخرى في لاحقا
نحن حقيقه
نرى
الحوار بحذاته مفيد جدا
وحقيقه ثمار هذا الحوار ايضا مهم لكن نحن
في الخطوات الاولى همم لا نسرع ولا نبطئ
نريد ان نصل الى النتيجه وكلنا نعلم بان
العلاقات همم
علاقات ايران مع جيرانها لا تتميز
بالانتقائيه ونحن نريد العلاقات الحسنه بل
الممتازه مع جميع جيراننا نحن الان طيبه
مع دوله قطر همم
وبالمناسبه نهنئكم وان نهنئ دوله قطر
بمناسبه كاس العالم
وهذا هو يعتبر نجاح
لجميع ابنائنا في الاقليم ولجميع الدول
الاسلاميه والعربيه
والدول الاقليميه همم بين القوسين
العلاقات الطيبه مع السلطنه علاقت طيبه مع
مع الكويت واكيد المشاهدون يعرفون بان همم
نحن همم طوال السنه الفائته والتي
تبلورت بشعار
الاولويه للجيران في الحقيقه رجع همم سفير
الكويتي والسفير الاماراتي الى الى ايران
ونحن مع السعوديه دون الانتقائيه ان- ننظر
الى اعاده العلاقات الباب من جهتنا مفتوحه
ومثل ما سمعنا من وزير خارجيه السعوديه
حيث قال همم ايادينا ممدوده ونحن نشد على
هذه الايادي الممدوده
طيب
هل حدد موعد
لقاء جديد في العراق في بغداد
لقاء
سعودي ايراني برعايه عراقيه باختصار
حتى الان لم يحدث
حتى الان لم يحدد طيب اشرت الى ان الباب
مفتوح
للعلاقات
الدبلوماسيه مع مع السعوديه
ما المانع من
عوده هذه العلاقات ما هي الموانع التي ما
زالت متبقيه علما ان انه كانت هناك العديد
من جولات الحوار التي حصلت في العراق بين
الجانبين
نعم كما ذكرتهم خمس جولات في العراق
ونحن في تلك يعني الجولات ااا احرزنا بعض
بعض التقدم في مجالات عده ومنها طبعا
حج
السنه
الحاليه وفي الحقيقه الايرانيون
راحوا الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ورجعوا باطمئنان همم
بالنسبه الى الجمهوريه الاسلاميه الايراني
لا يوجد اي مانع في الحقيقه نحن مثل معقول
انه همم
الابواب مفتوحه والامر بالنسبه الى اعاده
العلاقات يعود الى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه نحن من جهتنا
مستعدون همم مثل هذه العلاقات والتي راح
تكون باذن الله طيبه وطبعا همم العلاقات
الايرانيه السعوديه اثر
للظروفها الاقليميه ونحنوه ندرك هذا الامر
ولذلك همم لا ظاهر يعني بالنسبه للجمهوريه
الاسلاميه الايرانيه همم اعاده العلاقات
اود بعض اجوبه باختصار سيد علي هل انتم
مستعدون وانت اشرت الى استعداد ايران
لعلاقات طيبه مع دول مع جيرانها تحديدا مع
دول الخليج هل انتم مستعدون لابرام
اتفاقيات امنيه وسياسيه همم مع دول الخليج
كامله باختصار
لعلمكم نحن قومنا بتوقيع همم على اتفاقيه
امنيه مع بعض الدول في خليج فارس مثل
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وسلطنه عمان ولا
يمنع بان توقع على اتفاقيات اخرى مع الدول
الاخرى وكذلك نحن مستعدون ل- همم اجتماع
اقليمي مثل ما اشار اليه الوزير الايراني
في منتدى طهران لوزراه خارجيه وزاره
الدفاع والماء للتعاون والعراق وايران
وسوان في الاتفاقات الثنائيه او الاتفاقات
الجماعيه ايران هي مستهده لذلك همم
اللافته بعض الدول الخليجيه هنا تلعب دورا
في محاوله تقريب وجوهات النظر بين ايران
والولايات المتحده للعوده الى الاتفاق همم
النووي هل هذه الجهود
ما زالت مستمره في ضوء المواقف التي
سمعناها مؤخرا من الجانب الامريكي وحتى
ايضا من الجانب الايراني
طبعا هناك جهود من عده دول ومنها دوله قطر
الشقيقه وسلطنه عمان الشقيقه والعراق
الشقيق ونحن نرحب مثل هذه الادوار ايران
ما وقفها بالنسبه الى الملف النووي واضح
جدا نحن مع الاتفاق نريده هذا الاتفاق لكن
اعترف الاخر قد يرى الاوراق ايران يريد ان
تريد ان تكون همم هذا الاتفاق يضمن همم
مصالحها المشروعه في الاتفاق النووي وكذلك
همم ترفع العقوبات الظالمه ال- ال- الجهود
ما زالت مستمره حتى اللحظه
الجهود لا تزال مستمره هل هل لدى ايران اي
خطه بديله في ملوي لم تنجح هذه الجهود خطه
بي كما يقال
طبعا ايران مع يعني سيناريو او فلان ايه
ولكن الوزير الايراني مع الوزير الايراني
دكتور رامي العبدليان اكد قبل
ايام بان هذا الباب ليس مفتوحا الى الابد
لكن ايران تفضل سيناريو الف
واتصور حسب ما افهم سيناريو 1000 مقابل
1000 ولو لا سمح الله سيناريو بي مقابل
سيناريوكي نتحدث عن الحوارات همم هل هناك
هل تلقيتهم اي دعوه
لدعوه عراقيه ربما همم لحوار مع مصر حوار
ايراني مصري مثلا على غرار الحوار
الايراني السعودي في بغداد
حقيقه ااه نحن نرحب
بالدور العراق الاقليمي البناء في جميع
الاخوه العراقيون سوان اكان في العلاقات
الايرانيه السعوديه او المصريه الايرانيه
او الاردنيه الايرانيه وهناك حديث من
سمعناه ومن اخواننا العراقيين بان هذا هو
مطلوب
تعرفون بان مكتبه رعايه مصالح المصريه همم
همم
موجود مفتوح يعني في في طهران ويقوم
بنشاطاته كما ان قائم بالاعمال الاردنيه
المملكه الاردنيه الهاشميه موجود بطهران
ويقوم مناشاطاته وحقيقه في
لقائنا مع
همم الملك عبد الله ملك الاردن تم الحديث
عن همم
افاق للعلاقات الايرانيه الاردنيه ولا
ظاهر كما قلت يعني بالنسبه لراما مصر همم
جمهوريه مصر العربيه ايران هي مستعده لذلك
ايضا
شكرا جزيلا لك علي رضا عنايه مساعد وزير
الخارجيه الايراني والمدير العام لدائره
شؤون الخليجيه في الخارجيه الايرانيه
حدثتنا من طهران